what's up guys bang bang i'm on the road
this week but you didn't think i was
gonna miss out on our bitcoin weekly
update that's right there's lots of
geopolitical conflict going on lots of
uncertainty in the market many people
asking what the hell is going on bitcoin
should it be going up should it be going
down is it going to be used to evade
sanctions is it going to be used to do
good in the world for people who are
fleeing ukraine or elsewhere well let's
dive into some of the metrics and see
exactly what's going on using on-chain
metrics and macro data here we go so
first if we get started we got to look
at price and bitcoin's been trading
somewhere between 40 000 and 44 000 for
a couple of days now that's up about 20
to 25
since the invasion of ukraine started
there's a lot of people have been
talking about bitcoin is it a safe haven
asset or is it not and it looks like
many people around the world the market
in general is going ahead and placing a
premium on the asset we also know that
bitcoin has been trading at an all-time
high when measured in rubles but if we
look at the underlying network itself
those statistics is that bitcoin is
trading somewhere around 750 to 800
billion dollars in market cap we know
that about 90 percent of the supply has
already been issued and of course there
are about a million active addresses
every single day miners are being paid
between 35 and 45 million dollars per
day sitting right around 40 million
dollars today and then ultimately if we
go and we look bitcoins actually down
almost 20 percent over the last 12
months but it's up 350 over the last two
years that's because of the base effect
last year bitcoin went from thirty
thousand dollars in january all the way
up to sixty four thousand dollars in
about march time frame and so ultimately
that base effect is affecting that one
year return but bitcoin still only has
spent about 300 days above the current
position so about 94
of all of bitcoin's life has been at a
lower price point if you bought then and
held till now you are in profit
ultimately if we go ahead and we take a
look at the compound annual growth rate
what we see is that bitcoin is still
compounding annually at 145
over the last 10 years and that five
year sharp ratio sitting above 1.5
making it an incredibly attractive
portfolio diversification tool and also
a great risk reward if we then come in
and we take a look at a number of
different metrics that show us the
behavior of those holding bitcoin or
various activity on the bitcoin network
we can see in this week's blockwear
intelligence newsletter written by will
clemente and the team over at blockware
it's showing that there's three separate
metrics that are all telling us that
we're near a bottom doesn't guarantee
that we're actually at the bottom but
definitely that we're nearing one we can
look at a bitcoin entity adjusted
dormancy flow again very very low
compared to historical numbers if we
then go and look at the entity adjusted
mvrv comparing bitcoin's valuation
relative to the value stored in the
network again relative basis very low
and then ultimately we look at the mayor
multiple one of the classic metrics to
measure bitcoin compared to the past
price movements we see that the mayor
multiple is quite low as well and so
ultimately these metrics don't tell us
hey you should buy or hey you should
sell but what it does show is this on a
relative basis bitcoin is drastically
undervalued to where it's been in the
past according to a number of these
network metrics now many of you are
probably wondering yourself why is it
that bitcoin is being bid up during a
time of international conflict of
uncertainty and chaos well lynn alden
had a great tweet over this week where
she said that the world collectively has
about 15 trillion dollars in official
sovereign international reserves less
than 2.5 trillion of that is gold the
rest is fiat and the fiat portion can be
frozen for that country by other
countries even a sizable percentage of
the gold portion is international
custodial meaning that many countries
let other countries hold it for them the
vast majority of sovereign reserves are
permissioned assets and thus aren't
really sovereign of course if you have
an asset like bitcoin that is digital
that's decentralized that it is
resistant to both censorship and seizure
there's a lot of people in the world
that are waking up to why that may be
important moving forward into the future
and so ultimately this is why we're
seeing bitcoin get bit up so there's
many people saying maybe in the words of
satoshi i should get some in case it
catches on but one of the things to be
really careful about is that the
narrative of russians or ukrainians
buying bitcoin that we're not seeing
that in the data yet this tweet from
willy woo on march 2nd shows that local
bitcoins the peer-to-peer bitcoin
trading volume in both ukraine and
russia are not showing any significant
uptick and so what's more likely is that
people elsewhere outside of russia and
ukraine are realizing the value of
bitcoin they may even be speculating
that russians and ukrainians could go
buy bitcoin and therefore they're all
going and buying it even though they're
not in the conflict zone and so
ultimately bitcoin being up materially
since the beginning of this geopolitical
conflict and invasion is something to
keep your eye on but remember there's a
whole macro world out there we're
watching everything from energy prices
increase we're watching movements in the
yield curves every single piece of the
global economy is under duress or is
under movement right now and so you've
got to be able to look at bitcoin
through the global macro lens it's
really hard to do and so ultimately if
you simply are like me dollar cost
averaging and saying it doesn't matter
what happens in the world i want my
bitcoin and i'm gonna keep holding them
then you're probably gonna have a lot
less stressful life right now i hope
this is helpful and we'll be back to
normal programming next week hope you
guys have a great rest of your weekend
and talk next week hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time